obrigado a todos
olhava manuel vamos olhar só estou viva
feira pelo convite a toda esta produção
fantástica
é um grande prazer estar aqui eu vou
falar sobre como é que se chamava você
tá na primeira parte não chegou mas não
ficou falar sobre ondas gravitacionais
né nova janela para o universo as novas
vistas para o universo existem agora
duas novas catedrais estão nos estados
unidos uma em reforma estava ótimo
outra invenção gustavo vianna é
separados por aproximadamente três mil
quilômetros foram consumidas que o
website foi insidiosa tecnologia de que
o califórnia institute of technology
também conhecido como é caltech
vamos chegar à luz é 300 mil quilômetros
estamos parada por três mil quilômetros
e portanto máximo aos propagam será o
uso de mora um centésimo de segundo
a erro a outro confessa o observatório o
ego ele que significa laser
interferometer habitantes o ex101 uma
vista aérea de um observatório se vêem
um braço que tem quatro quilômetros
pronto socorro laser o outro lance que
tem quatro quilômetros no centro está em
casa com o centro de operações está no
meio do deserto
acho que este é é a vista do
observatório lago em sangue no estado da
luisiana não está no zero
uma estação em rio branco e também tem
quatro quilômetros de extensão e propeno
equipamento quatro anos para o outro
quem não puder ir aos estados unidos ver
estas quebrava quem não quiser se o cara
estava machucando ou estavam viana poder
e pisa na itália e lá tem o chamado
observatório virgo que havíamos réplica
européia os dois observatórios estados
unidos que os braços pretende quantos
tem três quilômetros de extensão
aqui está o interior um dos braços
três quilômetros em virgo e vemos uma
física atestar a existência do material
isto funciona como é que funciona
este instrumento quatro quilômetros com
braços quatro quilômetros
eu acho a idéia é injetar um raio laser
no instrumento
a seguir dois existe um divisor dodô faz
o indivíduo faz em 2 fez idênticos uma
travessa 4 que vamos na direção ou
travessa quatro anos na direção
perpendicular cada um dos flashes batom
no espelho e volta
se passar uma onda gravitacional seu
instrumento
este faz cumprimento vai vibrar a de
comprimento com vara
diferentemente de um lado o outro se não
passar nava os faz
não somos afetados eu sou recolhidos
outra vez no que era um divisor passa a
ser um coletor são coletados no corretor
são enviados protetor que se nada
acontecer esta foi tal maneira que
realmente nada acontece
nada vai atuar no setor
então os fãs cancel chamada como as
ondas de luz é uma onda joão cancelo
lance e nada acontece
se passar uma onda gravitacional os os
braços comprimento os braços musa de
frente de um lado e do outro o que
acontece é que não cancela e vais
observar alguma coisa então isto é enfim
ele realmente como funciona
vai ser enterrado em um caixão erro zero
é uma afronta o inter finalmente foram
inventados por michael só nos estados
unidos há mais de 130 anos atrás e foram
são usados por muitas coisas que são
usados para tentar em ondas
gravitacionais
agora o light teto é essencialmente um
ruído tem pinta é muito ruim e tudo
vibra e portanto só está sempre lembrado
só estou sempre a vi lá é muito ruim de
rodízio arroz nos tratores que andam por
lá vocês possam imaginar que está sendo
concluído e é muito complicado mesmo
stack azul extrair alguma informação de
frente é como está o futebol ouro tô
aqui ela juntou 100 mil pessoas tentaram
vivíamos uma conversa 30 momento
consegue fazer mas tem que sair um sinal
para fazer essa intenção não é a mesma
coisa aqui
só que aqui tem que ser desenvolvido o
que chama análise da distração de
informação a partir do ruído para se ter
a ferramenta o sinal está lá embute vivo
e que consegue extrair não foi um foi
necessário fazer isso
além disso como é que se faça essa
extração de sinal é chamada através da
técnica filtragem por identificação que
a minha tradição de machu picchu e foi
desenvolvida sem precedentes para se
conseguir extrair um sinal de uma onda
gravitacional
que bater nos setores laicos para fazer
se essa filtragem por identificação
somos site padrões ondas que vão chegar
pra quando chegar esse padrão no meio do
rio
existe essa identificação e visar temos
aqui um sinal número ruim então foi
necessário padrões desenvolver padrões
muito possíveis formas de onda que
pudessem chegar e isso foi um esforço
muito grande em termos de computação
numérica e analítica para se conseguir
perceber que forma de onda enxerga e
sabíamos que as formas de ondas que
poderão chegar era através de espinar
espirais colisão posterior de pôr a
clínica mostra hoje atrás
aconteceu o que todos queremos e que
alguns achavam que nunca ia acontecer
mas que alguns nossos bravos com grande
lá como é o meu caso e a partir de
setembro de 2015 com suave rumores em 50
o número final no lago 2016 a revista
mais importante da música nacional
a revista physical review letters as
cartas publicou um artigo da colaboração
lago estados unidos
o governo não estava funcionando mas
qualquer maneira essa conversação sobre
a primeira detenção de um homem
gravitacional em catorze sistema 2015
às 10 horas e 50 45 horas na rua eu por
acaso não senti nada porque estará
vermelha mas lago vibrou como se
esperava e vejam que existe a intenção
do lago reforma e atenção do lago o
livro está no padrão de onda é
completamente idêntica kiyota encarnado
e evitar o uso está atrás comparado com
o ranking o que é completamente deles
era muito importante ter dois
a funcionária iguais para saber que eu
tinha cinco pura carro que tinha vivido
esta vibração
temos duas vibrações iguais é porque
realmente aconteceu alguma coisa
vibraram da mesma maneira em paraty por
aproximadamente o sinal separado por
aproximadamente um centésimo de segundo
e deste sinal podemos extrair várias
informações
então o que nós temos que ver é que o ar
aqui é o tempo
então tá aqui andar o tempo então nada
acontece aqui
o tempo passa tudo igual começa neste
final nos ecrãs
então vemos que nada acontece começa a
vibrar a vibrarem tem sido cada vez
maior com a mesma freqüência cada vez
menor é cada vez maior tanto mais rápido
e depois volta tudo a mesma coisa votar
obviamente que vamos comparar este sinal
com os museus que nós temos da
computação numérica para que possam dar
um sinal aos estudantes e isso fez aqui
está o que a nasa numérica constrói para
uma conclusão buracos negros que chega
no bairro tem muito humor ou 0 25 e 0 40
e 50 pontos hoje dois décimos de segundo
e foi o que aconteceu
como é que está a interpretar de maneira
acontece que eu ligasse unifica o
comprimento
o do laser mudou alguma coisa pra vocês
terem uma idéia mudou praticamente nela
veze ovada menos oito metros em 4
quilômetros
o tamanho do núcleo tamanho do próton e
veda -3 10 - 15 metros é mil vezes norma
comum também mil vezes menor que o
tamanho do próton até quase nada foi o
desenvolvimento da tecnologia pra lá
aponta para se conseguir detectar este
sinal e ver esta mudança cumprimento de
um dos braços e vocês vejam que tem um
padrão braço aumenta diminui amendoim o
menino pois aumenta mais e mais rápido
depois desaparece
então o que é que isto é são dois
buracos negros no caso foram dois
gatinhos com 30 massas watch cada um
significa que não tem aproximadamente
300 quilômetros em órbita um com o outro
a rolarem com a terra está à volta do
sol neste caso com dois brasileiros em
rotação estão aproveitando a energia
pura ambição gravitacional vê la perla
energia o raio da horta vai diminuindo
vão aumentando cada vez mais velha
também mãe da vilã até se juntar num só
buraco negro
existem três fácil mais ou menos claras
aqui a fase de espiral regressiva em que
os vão diminuir relativamente devagar a
órbita o raio da órbita a faz confusão
em que os realmente junto à fase de
deliberação final em que já atuam junto
vibram limita a intervenção é
gravitacional e depois outra vez junto
então este evento histórico de setembro
de 2015 mostrou que comprar qual tivemos
nós temos mostrou que os brasileiros
tinham mais ou menos
32 32 mas só acho que era um orgulho
final de 61 massa solar significa que 3
mas sua acho que é muita massa foi
revelada em dinheiro fácil
só que está a uma distância de mil e
duzentos milhões de anos
portanto quando cheguei aqui chega um
sinal fraco nessa tecnologia para tentar
não queria mostrar pra falar pra vocês
fico lá que foi o que envolveu o os
físicos teoria da gravitação esforço que
foi o amor
aaaah física a dedicação para conseguir
chegar a 14 em 2015
primeiro temos que começar com aids em
público as equações da teoria da
relatividade geral
ketlin a gravitação do mundo ea visão
que nós temos o conjunto é fundamental
que o índice mostrou que é válida diz
que uma quantidade do chamado g e outra
continua a ter em que gerir por exemplo
o financiamento espaço mas também
sabemos que passa é mais que passa
espaço tempo e ter presente a matéria
estão ligadas pré sal há duas coisas
completamente diferentes estão ligadas
o grande físico já não eu a face que
prestam disso século passado que esta
emoção diz que o espaço diz a matéria
por onde levo ver o sol tem que se ver a
volta até ea matéria eles o espaço como
se curvar o sol lixo como é que o espaço
fica curva pra terra pois choveu daquela
maneira
em 1916 tentar formular a teoria de
einstein pensou certeza que têm serviço
gravitacional está incluído ainda teve a
adesão à greve nacional e driblou uma
forma para a reeleição gravitacional
acerto foi com muita pressa
errou completamente na forma
eu me mostrou que havia uma revista
chamada monopol mas a regra não é muito
mais complicado que isso só existe uma
solução com a proposta significa fonte
vai me tiram dinheiro do sinaes tem que
se mover uma forma um bocadinho visita
não pode só pensar em um site a eleição
do monopólio mas em vez de forma
esquisita a intervenção da copa exemplo
dois brasileiros 1 e volta do outro um
vez um caso que não tem intervenção
essa forma de vapor em 1906 foi
corrigida por o próprio em 1918 e depois
que o grande astro o físico inglês
cambridge era então em 1922 mostrou que
havia um fator dois na forma quanto ela
então foi o primeiro a saber qual era a
forma correta da versão nacional pois
muitas discussões durante décadas se
ondas gravitacionais existiam ou não no
ar localmente 30 anos inscrições têm um
físico estava em inglaterra o pirani as
ondas gravitacionais são efeito da
curvatura maré
nós chamamos de efeito maré curvatura
é o que diz ser a audiência mar é o que
fala
não tive nêutrons são forças então as
marés da terra mostram que uma parte de
virada para a lua ea parte do lado
contrário tem maré alta é uma força
diferencial aqui puxa mais equipas
femininas com 61 das marés são forças
gravitacionais são forças armadas são
forças reais
pirani percebeu que o facto das ondas
gravitacionais existiam por duas partes
com as próximas de colocar mãos umas das
outras
vivi essas ondas gravitacionais e
portanto foi a primeira vez que se
conseguiu perceber que ondas
gravitacionais de facto exista um estudo
teórico em 1967 que torna o caltech
começou a desenvolver toda a teoria
vamos crescer acredita sinais de forma
sistemática
em 1974 e nos anos subseqüentes ao
sentar ela também prestam descobrir o
pulsar binário está bastante afastado
demonstraram que orbita a terra a
energia está lá o passar dos dias
orb tapera energia e eles fizeram isso
ao longo de vários anos 15 anos devido à
emissão de ondas gravitacionais portanto
a pedra de energia do pulsar que os
observavam batia com o que era previsto
pela atividade geral tão bem que eu
receber o nobel em 1993 1975 vai se
render mais a equipa do caltech
encontraram se iniciar um projeto laico
que era uma ideia vai 1970 antes fui vai
ter realmente a ideia de que o inter
frontlights a muitos quilômetros
era uma coisa inimaginável na altura
poderia ser cento para tentar ondas
gravitacionais e ao parar e correto para
tentarmos as retenções chamaram o andré
vai ter um músico seja um gênio da
física experimental e chamamos os três
ela troca o ego
chamaram também bege vinha de física de
partículas e saber coordenar projetos
grandes e com grandes corporações e
construíram os dois observatórios que
mostrará em 1996 em 2002 lago com suas
músicas por ondas gravitacionais
foi nessa altura que os vitorianos
juntamos ao ego
e finalmente em 2015 as ondas
gravitacionais são detetáveis pela
primeira vez na história da humanidade
então a data histórica as vagas foram
geradas pela colisão dois buracos negros
30 marcas fortes e não um evento teve
origem em uma distância cuja lógica 1200
milhões
jesus em 2017 outro evento importante
sem ter vários vagões já tem cinco ou
seis eventos detenção de ondas
gravitacionais por
porém a conclusão do resgate next em
2017 erro
outro evento importantíssimo que é é é a
conclusão duas estrelas de neutrões do
estrelas de neutrões quando concluírem a
escola e também e consegue observar e
foram observados não só em um dos hits
nacionais como em é é no espectro
eletromagnético por todos os tipos de
telescópios de raios gama até a rádio
finalmente no dia 3 de outubro é
anunciado o prêmio nobel de física que
por esta altura você já deve saber quem
ganhou o pan não fizer vai ser o grande
imagine agora protetor berj grande diria
o grande gestor toda a conversar e o que
torna o grande teórico
por trás dessa tensão e o anúncio
perminov disse que a real academia das
ciências da suécia decidiu atribuir o
prémio nobel da física 2010 exceto
computar para rivais e outro estava em
conjunto para beber chique torna por
contribuições decisivas decisivas
protetor lago ea observação de ondas
gravitacionais times a eu só quero dizer
que pertençam a um centro assistencial
só apresenta o centro através de que a
votação
trabalhamos nesta área ondas
gravitacionais buracos negros e várias
outras assuntos e em grande orgulho nem
se realmente foi r valeu a pena ter
vivido para ver a extensão das ações
[Aplausos]
[Música]